but the president's chances will depend
an awful lot on which Democrat runs
against him who gets the nomination
sadly for the president's opponent will
most certainly not be medium blogger
beta or orc he's polling at about two
percent that's good news for America by
the way how do we know well watch this
this weekend no work spoke at the New
Hampshire Democratic Party convention he
spoke for just about ten minutes it was
amazing how much lunacy he managed to
cram in to such a short period of time
but it began his speech by denouncing
the country's racist as he often does
from the very beginning bado told us
America has been an evil nation this is
a country that has been defined by
foundational systemic endemic racism
since the very founding of this country
August 20th of 1619 the first time that
a kidnapped African was brought here
against his will and made to serve as a
slave to build the greatness and the
success and the wealth of his country
which his descendants would never be
able to fully participate in this is the
reality of the United States of America
and sooner or later it was going to find
us it wasn't a matter if it was a matter
of when what a disgusting country this
is his bado and because America is
fundamentally immoral Americans don't
deserve the constitutional liberties
they have had from the very beginning
President bado he said would create a
national gun registry of all firearms in
the country and then user industry to
seize the firearms of law-abiding
Americans this is a country that has
produced the leadership that will ensure
that we not only have universal
background checks and red flag laws and
end the sale of those weapons of war but
there we go the necessary steps further
as politically difficult as they may be
a gun registry in this country licensing
for every American who owns a firearm
and every single one of those ar-15s and
ak-47s will be bought back so they're
not on our streets not in our homes do
not take the lives of our fellow
Americans ah the most nauseating kind of
trust fund politics in bado just
personifies but really he was only half
done that seemed like a lot of insanity
to you but bado got all of that out of
the way in about six minutes he went on
to explain that America is so evil so
racist that it's responsible for all of
the world's problems
according to beta America cause is not
simply global warming but also
everything bad that makes people leave
their countries and come here listen
the violence the persecution the
droughts caused not by god nor by mother
nature but by you and me our excesses
our inaction in the face of the facts
and the science the climate change that
we are producing do Trust Funds make you
decadent and stupid bethe roots
existence kind of answers that question
doesn't it but he's got ideas for us
what is the penance we need to pay for
being a sinful a country as we are bado
says we must give amnesty to every
single illegal alien within our borders
right now we're going to legalize the
presence of more than ten million in the
United States beginning with dreamers
who will never again fear deportation
back to a country they do not know
because we will make them US citizens in
this their true home country